Como regalo de cumpleaños, Zoe le dio a su
sobrina una alcancía bancaria electrónica,
la cual, muestra la cantidad total de dinero en la alcancía así como la cantidad total de monedas.
Después de depositar cierta cantidad de monedas
de 5 centavos y de 25 centavos,
la alcancía mostró lo siguiente, el dinero es 2 pesos,
el número de monedas son 16.
¿Cuántas monedas de 5 centavos
y cuántas de 25 centavos puso Zoe en la alcancía?
Y bueno, lo primero que vamos a hacer
es definir variables,
así que voy a decir sea "n" igual
al número de monedas de 5 centavos
y sea "q" igual al número
de monedas de 25 centavos, perfecto.
Ahora, lo primero que sé, es que la cantidad
de monedas que voy a tener son la cantidad
de monedas que tengo de 5 centavos más la
cantidad de monedas que tengo de 25 centavos,
es decir, "n" más "q".
"n" más "q" es la cantidad de monedas
que tengo en mi alcancía,
que por cierto,
me dice mi alcancía que son 16,
el número de monedas que tengo son 16
y por lo tanto "n" más "q" es igual a 16.
Ahora, aquí ya tenemos la primera ecuación
pero para sacar la segunda ecuación,
en lo que nos tenemos que fijar es en la cantidad
de dinero que tenemos con las monedas de 5 centavos,
es decir, 0.05 por "n" y a eso sumarle
la cantidad de dinero que tenemos en las monedas
de 25 centavos, por lo tanto, 0.25, si estamos
hablando de pesos o 25 centavos
por la cantidad de monedas que tenemos
de 25 centavos, es decir por "q".
Y bueno, de hecho hasta podemos hacer un ejemplo,
si "q" vale 4 y "n" vale 0, entonces tendríamos
4 por .25 lo cual es 1 y 0 por 0.5, pues esto
no me daría nada,
entonces aquí tendríamos 1 peso solamente.
Sin embargo,
lo que sí sé es que tiene que ser igual a 2 pesos,
estos tiene que ser igual a 2 pesos
porque es justo lo que me está diciendo
mi alcancía electrónica, que la cantidad
de monedas que yo tengo de 5 centavos
multiplicado por lo que valen, por 5 centavos,
más la cantidad de monedas que yo tengo de 25 centavos, multiplicado por lo que valen las monedas,
es decir, 25 centavos,
esto tiene que ser igual a 2 pesos y aquí ya tenemos un sistema de ecuaciones con dos incógnitas
y con dos ecuaciones, por lo tanto
vamos a intentar resolver esto
pero por el método de sustitución.
Así que aquí en la primera ecuación,
voy a despejar a "q" y "q" es igual a 16 menos "n",
de aquí estoy pasando para acá
solamente restando "n" de ambos lados de la ecuación
y como yo sé que "q"
vale igual a 16 menos "n",
entonces lo que voy a hacer
es sustituir el valor de "q" aquí adentro,
en lugar de esta "q", voy a poner
lo que vale la "q" en mi primera ecuación.
Y recuerda que esto es cierto porque se tienen
que cumplir ambas ecuaciones simultáneamente
y entonces me queda, 0.05 por "n" más 0.25
por "q", pero recuerda,
vamos a sustituir a "q",
entonces en lugar de "q" voy a poner 16 menos "n",
0.25 por "q" pero "q" vale 16 menos "n",
eso es lo que nos dice la primera ecuación
y esto tiene que ser igual a 2 pesos,
ok, ahora date cuenta que ya tengo una ecuación
con solamente una incógnita
y ahora voy a distribuir el 0.25 y dice,
0.25 por 16 y 0.25 por "-n",
0.25 por 16, es lo mismo que .5 por 8
que es lo mismo que 4 por 1,  es 4
y después, 0.25 por "-n" es lo mismo que -0.25 por "n"
y esto tiene que ser igual a 2 pesos.
Ahora, lo que voy a hacer es
restar de ambos lados de la ecuación 4,
de tal manera que yo pueda sumar estos
dos que tienen que ver con "n",
"0.05n" menos "0.25n"
pues esto es lo mismo que...
a ver, aquí tengo 5 centavos y aquí tengo
-25 centavos, pues esto me quedaría
-20 centavos entonces de estos dos, de una vez,
si los reduzco me queda "-0.2n"...
"-0.20n"...
-0.2... "-0.20n"...
y bueno, vamos a seguir ya que redujimos todo
lo que tenía que ver con "n" y no olvidemos
a este cuadro, entonces más 4 esto tiene
que ser igual a 2 pesos...
a 2.00, ahora si yo resto 4 de ambos lados
de la ecuación, voy a empezar a despejar
a "n" entonces -4, -4 aquí,
¿y entonces qué me queda?
Del lado izquierdo estos dos se van y
solamente me queda "-0.20n"...
"-0.20n" esto es lo mismo que 2 menos 4,
lo cual es -2.
¡Muy bien! y ahora para sacar el valor de
"n" lo que voy a hacer es dividir ambos lados
de la ecuación entre -0.2, entre -0.2 de
este lado ó -0.20 pero los dos son lo mismo
y del otro lado también tengo que dividir
entre -0.2, recuerda que los 0 a la derecha
después del punto decimal no cuentan
y por lo tanto, me queda -2 entre -0.2,
y ahora sí, "n" es igual a -2 entre -0.2, aquí menos
entre menos me da más y 2 entre 2 me da 1
y después recorro el punto decimal
y me queda 10.
"n" es igual a 10 y ya puedo sacar "q"
de manera muy rápida.
Aquí dice que "q" es igual a 16 menos "n"
y por lo tanto "q" es igual a 16 menos 10,
lo cual es 6.
"n" vale 10 y "q" vale 6, es decir,
que la cantidad de monedas que tenemos
de 5 centavos son 10
y la cantidad de monedas que tenemos
de 25 centavos tienen que ser 6, perfecto
.
¡Ya llegamos a la solución!
Y vamos a ver si realmente se cumplen
las dos ecuaciones,
claramente estas dos suman 16,
10 más 6 me da 16, esto es muy fácil,
ahora si yo quiero sacar
la cantidad de dinero que tenemos,
pues tendría que multiplicar éste por 5 centavos,
lo cual me daría pues 50 centavos ó 0.50 pesos,
0.50 pesos y 6 por .25  es lo mismo que
1.50 pesos o dicho de otra manera,
1 peso con 50 centavos
y si ahora sumamos las dos,
claramente esto me da 2 pesos.
Y por lo tanto estamos bien.